[Music]
dear girl mine my name is Tracy and as
it stated my 19th birthday and I'll be
seeing my educational sciences thanks to
the influence of worldly education such
as yourself my question for you is what
do you think is the most beneficial
thing a scientist can do for the
community and what do you consider your
greatest accomplishment as a scientist
as an educator all the best and thank
you for your contributions for the
generations ahead of yours Tracy I'm
delighted that you are pursuing a career
in science we need as many
scientifically literate people as we can
in our society so that when it's time to
vote and make decisions about our future
we do it with an informed way with
science as the background so thank you
this is fabulous as far as my
contribution
that's very nice question I think it's
good getting young people excited about
science so in the future we'll have
scientifically literate people and what
we want is for people it's not just the
facts the facts are great they often
change as we learn more but the big
thing is to get the process of science
you make an observation your eyebrows go
up you save yourself my goodness what
caused that then you come up with an
idea or a hypothesis of what made that
effect happen it's a phenomenon that you
observe and then you come up with a way
to test it you test it and then you see
what happened and compare what you
thought would happen with what did
happen and you're right compare your
hypothesis to the outcome if we can get
that across to as many people as
possible we can Tracy dare I say it
change the world it's a great question
you